[Music]
in a freshwater lake a specific area has
recently witnessed a substantial
increase in alal blooms considering this
the overall condition of the lake is
best described by which of the following
acidic
oligotrophic utopic or
hypertrophic so this is a basic concept
problem as such there's not much in the
manual that's going to help in this case
so instead let's walk through our list
of possible answers and explain what
each of them
mean an acidic lake is one where the pH
is below seven typically this is caused
by acid rain or biological
activity oligotrophic Lakes have low
nutrient levels and typically have clear
water with limited alal
growth
utopic Lakes have high nutrient levels
and often experience significant alkohol
growth and finally hypertrophic Lakes
have extremely high nutrient levels
leading to excessive algal growth and
other water quality
issues in this case the problem states
that a substantial increase in alal
blooms
has occurred but only in a specific area
of the lake this vague statement would
lead me to remove the low and the high
answers leaving utopic as the only thing
left we are also could cross out acidic
since this is related to pH rather than
nutrients as always with Concept
problems if you don't understand don't
remember or have never heard of the
topic before just save it for later or
take a guess and move on your overall
time management on the exam is going to
be more important than your performance
on one individual problem and that's
it